we've already had several videos where
we talk about the types of
markets that we might look at in
economics at one end you might have
perfect competition let's write perfect
comp and this is where you have many
firms they what they produce is not
differentiated there's no barriers to
entry and in that situation we have
looked at that the market price the
firms just have to take that market
price and that market price is going to
describe what their marginal revenue is
going to be no matter how much each of
those individual firms produce they're
just going to get that market price so
that marginal revenue will be that
market price but then we looked at a
whole sort of what we could call
imperfectly competitive firms
imperfectly
imperfect
competition at the extreme you have the
monopoly
where you only have one firm in the
market huge barriers to entry and so
that that company or that firm
essentially is the market and so their
demand curve for their product
essentially is the market demand curve
but in between you have things like
monopolistic competition right over
there and in monopolistic competition
you have many firms that are competing
but they're all differentiated in some
way and there are some barriers to entry
a good example of monopolistic
competition or imperfect competition
might be the athletic shoe market in the
athletic shoe market you have many
competitors you have your nike adidas
reebok and i could keep listing names
and they are all differentiated in their
own way they all have their own brands
which they've built up over time they
have associations with certain sports
figures some of their shoes might be
perceived as better in certain
categories but they are also competing
with each other so the competition is
that they're competing with each other
but you could consider it monopolistic
competition because only nike can sell
well nike shoes and so you can imagine a
demand curve for say only nike shoes so
in an imperfect competition every firm
would have their own unique demand curve
and the how much they produce actually
will affect the price that they get for
the product or the service and what
we're going to see in this video is when
we're dealing with imperfect competition
the demand curve the price isn't exactly
what marginal revenue is going to be and
to understand that let's look at a
simple model here
so right over here i have a very simple
model of a demand curve for a firm in an
imperfectly competitive market and you
can see here that the more that that
firm produces of its goods the less the
lower pricing can get for that good
and we can see very clearly this is a
classic downward sloping demand curve
but what's going to be really
interesting is to think about what is
going to be the marginal revenue
especially the marginal revenue in a
world where
if they sell one unit they get 32.50 but
when they sell two units it's not like
they'll get 32.50 for one of those units
and then they'll get 25 for the second
unit if you're if you have a market
price out there for 25 you're going to
get 25 on all two units so even though
someone was willing to pay 3250 for one
they're still only going to pay 25
so let's think about what that does to
the marginal revenue i encourage you to
pause this video and try to fill out
this table yourself before i do it with
you
all right now let's do it together so
our total revenue obviously when we sell
nothing we have let me do this in
another color we have zero total revenue
now when we sell one unit at 32.50 well
then our total revenue is going to be
32.50 no surprise there now it's going
to get interesting when we sell two
units what's going to be our total
revenue
well both of those units are going to be
sold at 25 it's not like as i just said
it's not like that first person is still
willing to pay 3250 it's like hey your
market price is 25 that's what
everyone's going to pay so now your
total revenue is fifty dollars two times
twenty five dollars now when you go to
three
the market price that you can get is
17.50 let's see that is going to be
50 to
50.
50 250 of total revenue and then if you
if your market price was ten dollars you
could you could have a quantity of four
if you wanted to sell four you could do
so at a price of ten dollars you can
view it either way but then your total
revenue is going to be 40
now from this we can think about well
what's our marginal revenue
well our marginal revenue for that first
unit is the same as what the price of
that first unit is we went from 0 to
32.50 with that first unit so that's
32.50 right over here
but what about as we go from that first
unit to that second unit
well our units go up by one but our
revenue from 3250 to 50 goes up by 1750.
and so you're already seeing that
there's a discrepancy between our
marginal revenue and our price and we
can keep going
when we go from two to three units our
revenue only goes up by 250 and so
that's going to be our marginal revenue
and then something very interesting
happens as we go from three units to
four units our total revenue actually
goes down it goes down by 1250 negative
right over here
and that's because when the price gets
that low you are taking a hit on all of
the units that you're selling so you
actually get a lower total revenue right
over here and if we plot it we can we'll
see very clearly that the marginal
revenue curve departs from the demand
curve for that firm that's competing in
an imperfectly competitive market and so
we can see here at one unit our marginal
revenue is the same but at two units our
marginal revenue is
17.50 at three units our marginal
revenue is 250
and so we have a marginal revenue curve
that looks
more
like this so the big takeaways here are
that a firm that's operating in an
imperfectly competitive market it isn't
just a price taker it's not that no
matter how much it produces it's going
to get the same price it's going to have
its own unique demand curve because
there is some differentiation in the
market and so it's going to have a
downward sloping demand curve and
because of that downward sloping demand
curve you are also going to have a
downward sloping marginal revenue curve
and that marginal revenue curve is
actually going to be downward sloping at
a steeper rate
so when we start doing the firm analysis
of marginal cost and where does it
intersect the marginal revenue if you're
dealing with a firm that's operating in
a perfectly competitive market that
marginal revenue curve when we've seen
it before was horizontal but when we
think about that marginal revenue curve
for a firm in an imperfectly competitive
market that's going to be downward
sloping and it's going to be sloping
downward faster than its demand curve